good afternoon everyone my name is Kim
duto I'm from Arizona State University
I'm the director of computational
Sciences and informatics I'm going to be
presenting today on topics of interest
to my particular group and i hope to you
all about embracing the complexity of
cancer seeing forest and the trees as we
attempt to move forward in understanding
the world of cancer just to remind you
all the logistics will be taking
questions and answers at the end please
feel free to submit questions into the
question and answer box when we when I
complete the talk I will I will address
the questions that have come up through
the course of the talk read the
questions and provide answers on and
hope that you have a interesting and
enjoyable engagement so let me get
started we are in an interesting and I
think exciting transition in the in
biomedicine into personalized precision
genetically specified you name your lots
of wood names work where we are actually
changing the the very fabric of Medicine
to do being much more personalized this
change is about providing the right
targeting the right individual the right
care the right time in the right place
and in many ways is a fundamental
revolution as we embrace in personalized
or precision medicine the unique
molecular and biologic characteristics
of an individual but also it's a bit of
a renaissance as we not only return we
return to actually bringing it not only
the unique molecular characteristics of
an individual but the unique clinical
personal social as well as experiential
capacity of an individual
what's exciting about this revolution or
Renaissance is that in fact it's
actually very real it's one of my
favorite quotes is the future is already
here it's just not evenly distributed
and in fact this world of personalized
precision medicine is already in front
of us in many places so I from my local
newspaper I pull up advertisements from
the Washington Post or other places that
indicate places that are already welling
well engaged in performing this type of
precision of personalized medicine this
is from Vanderbilt University and I'll
show you where courtesy of my colleague
of me up leavey at Vanderbilt and the
outstanding work they're doing in my
cancer genome so what one can do in the
cancer field today is go to my cancer
genome select a particular disease in
this incidence melanoma choose a
particular gene of interest if you know
that you have a mutation in the b-raf
gene what is the specific mutation shown
here is that the 600 e alteration where
there's a/c there's a t2 a change in
b-raf and now one can derive
personalized precision medicine finding
out given that my melanoma has this
particular form of molecular alteration
I can drilling down on that side see see
what types of interventions are
available to me and what types of drugs
uh might be able to use you can see
there's BRAF inhibitors MEK inhibitors
kit inhibitors ah with specific degrees
of evidence associated with what might
actually happen and what rugs I might
use and what's been the outcomes
associated with this so we're actually
at the very beginning of this revolution
and seeing that in fact there's really
exciting things we could do today but
one of the critical things that you
might guess given I'm from the complex
adaptive systems group is is that while
this is an exciting beginning we are
just beginning to scratch the surface of
what it mean
to have precision or personalized
medicine specifically in the cancer
field which in many ways is has some of
the most interesting but still
challenging problems in this space so
what I mean so while looking at a single
gene is exciting and does provide real
opportunities today when we actually
look at what we know about cancer today
it's actually pretty complicated and in
fact way more complicated probably that
looking at a single mutation in a single
gene if we really want to be able to
have an impact in dealing with cancer so
let me spend a minute or two walking you
through when I say it's complicated what
I mean well first cancer is a complex
adaptive system so that if there's a key
take-home message I would like you to
get from this it's it's just exactly
that cancer is a complex adaptive system
so let me walk through that we know that
cancer start some in a base state and
accumulates alterations over time much
the same as any sort of evolutionary
adaptive system where it accumulates
multiple mutations and in fact creates a
new organ or conceivably depending on
your point of view organism within you
as an organ so it creates a
three-dimensional new collection of
genetic constitution that is has all the
complexity of any organ or organism but
has adapted and grown in real time these
portfolio mutations that occur over time
are not uniform in every cell as the
diagram attempts to show and in fact
number in the hundreds so there's not a
single mutation that occurs in cancer
but in fact literally dozens to hundreds
of mutations that occur in cancer or
alterations that occur in cancer the
next thing that's important to know in
this complex adaptive system is that
these alterations can occur in a variety
of ways as a consequence of the genome
project we spend a lot of time thinking
about how we would be altering the
specific constitutional DNA that's part
of an individual but we also recognize
that mute
stations in your DNA are but one way
that we can generate these alterations
one way we can generate them in addition
to mutations is not changing the copy
number of a gene we can generate
alterations by changing the expression
of the genes not just necessarily
through mutations we can generate
alterations by epigenetic mechanisms
mechanisms that aren't direct nucleic
acid modifications but in fact our
modifications to proteins histones and
other components that alter how the
nucleic acids are expressed or changed
we can have alterations not only in
these epigenetic processes but and also
other processes that are completely
outside of the expressed genome in the
traditional sense of protein coding
genes but G but actually genes or micro
RNAs that actually change the properties
of genes themselves and lastly we can
have processes that change these or
generate these adaptations or changes
that are completely outside of the
protein and or nucleic acid space of
glycolysis or other types of chemistry's
in a Cell so now if this isn't
complicated enough for you what we see
is that the complexity of the system is
manifest not only in the way in the
number of changes it can make the
three-dimensional structure and the
processes it can alter but it also
involves a number of complex biological
processes we've known for well over a
decade now that there are several key
processes that are important in the
development of cancer growth factor
independent evading apoptosis telomere
maintenance cell cycle regulation but
what is hidden by those simple soundbite
class says that we have to change aveda
practices or main or change the
maintenance of telomeres is that those
processes in themselves are products of
complex networks interacting collections
of molecules themselves and to actually
address growth factor independence one
can you take one of many of those genes
in those process in a given individual
but another individual can still be
altering those processes but change
another complete
different collection of those or another
individual can change yet another
collection of those so in fact we can
change we not only have the ability to
actually change individual genes but if
we look at it from the lens of a process
there's not a fixed set of genes that
need to be changed in order to alter a
particular property that's necessary for
the generation of cancer lastly if this
isn't complicated enough this in you
know this somatic collection of things
what we realize is that this somatic
changes occur in a very complex
environment of genetic constitution
there are anywhere between a million to
10 million individual variants that
exist in your genome that differ between
the DNA you inherited from your mom
versus the DNA you inherited from your
dad those variations can influence a
variety of endogenous processes how you
generate blood vessels the underlying
structure the cellular matrix how you
respond of what your basic immune
response is additionally they can not
only change those processes but actually
act at the interface to the environment
itself so they can change how we respond
to chemicals were exposed to viruses
were exposed to different hormonal
meloux's as well as how we would
actually respond to different
nutritional aspects so with all that
said I guess I would say that hopefully
cancer is not only complicated it's very
complicated so cancer is a complex
adaptive system why does this help us
well if we recognize the whole is more
than the sum of the parts it allows us
then to attack the system as a whole
rather than addressing the individual
pieces of cancer so recognizing the
cancer evolves over time there is not
one such thing as a static tumor
genotype or tumor molecular profile by
embracing the fact that it adapts it has
dynamic as opposed to static behavior by
realizing that it expresses emergent
properties that in fact looking at a
completely through a completely
reductionist mirror or completely
reduction this lens we will miss
emergent properties there are there are
pieces where the hole is more than
some of the individual parts it requires
multi-dimensional a transdisciplinary
study it requires us there's not a
single point of view that's of utility
in looking at cancer and that we need to
embrace its interdependencies that
cancer itself shares and manipulates
resource and exon fundamental level as a
complex adaptive system it's key
variable is information so what I'm
going to focus on here is those
interdependencies that the strategy that
my group looks at is how do we leverage
and understand and use these independent
dependencies that better understand how
cancer emerges and hopefully that to be
able to ultimately target how we will
intervene and change the performance so
our fundamental view of this is this
interconnected network based world so as
I'm going to move forward the key
metaphor that I'm going to use is these
networks of interconnections so early in
the cancer molecular Revolution piece of
personalized medicine the somatic
genetics of cancer drove the community
to consideration of network models when
one started looking at genome-wide
characterization such as Exxon see exome
sequencing RNA sequel genome sequencing
as I mentioned a moment there's
literally hundreds of mutations observed
but what was confounding is while those
hundreds of mutations were observed less
than five percent of them reoccurred
from individual to individual to
individual so there was an observation
of a very high frequency of the
observation a very high frequency gene
and or mutant gene specific mutations is
very rare it also observed that when we
look between tumor to tumor when we look
at mutational signatures or expression
signatures or epigenetic signatures
there's a ton of variation it's very
hard to find uniform coherent signatures
from individual to individual and it
also became clear that the
multi-dimensional data provided
apparently conflicting results
apparently conflicting until all this
data was projected onto biologic
processes
and biologic networks so here is one of
the earliest examples that emerged of
the Cancer Genome Atlas Project with
respect to the cancer with respect to
glioblastoma multiforme on gbms and what
they saw is a very complex pattern of
cancer at an individual gene level so
for instance if you look at EGF arm that
has a very high frequency of mutation
you look at her be too it has mutation
rates up less than ten percent and you
look at rasmussen less than two percent
but what we saw is when we project all
these various types of alterations on to
molecular networks there suddenly
emerged a coherence the chaos evaporates
and you can see that there's actually
systematic patterns and that different
cancers in different individuals are
targeting a common underlying biologic
set of interconnections and then
manipulating those particular processes
so these accumulations of these very
diverse patterns of alterations are
actually geared at disrupting these key
underlying networks and 11 projects onto
these networks you can see that for
instance the rasp pathway rather than
having single digit gene specific
mutations when we look at the raspberry
eighty-eight percent of the tumors
disrupt the rass pathway eighty-seven
percent disrupt the p53 signaling
pathway seventy-eight percent disrupt
our V signaling so we start to get
coherence by projecting the data into
these network models so my group has
been particularly interested given the
session that I'm in looking at the
quantitative approaches by which we can
find these processes so that we can
objectively find these processes rather
than just descriptively find that some
of the earliest work in my group was
done by my postdoc saw F Romney who is
now at bar-ilan University he developed
a tool that's now instantiated in the
program pathologist that has later taken
gravity or taken form in
a later publication by the group from
the UCSC in the paradigm work but Saul
published this work as you can see in no
2007 is the sort of first win
computationally approaching this state
of networks by looking at their
interactions so what do I mean by this
and how is this different than basic
signature analysis well first let's do
some let's look at how the algorithms
and the analytics actually work so
here's a cartoonish Network we can see
it's composed of three interaction nodes
and a total of one two three four five
different genes or as well as a cut as
well as this conflict de so five six
different interacting inputs and what we
do in this is then paint the data for
any given observation on this you can
see the ABCD efg at the bottom we can
press their state at the bottom and then
project that data onto the network
diagram itself and then compute at each
of the nodes as to whether in fact once
we've laid the individual genes state as
to whether we're getting coherence or
activation at each individual node so
what does this look like in practice so
let me walk through a specific example
so let's start by looking at node 1 and
the gene states for a B and C we can see
a is present B is absent and C is
present from the little cartoonish
things the arrowhead means that that
would activate the interaction and B if
it was present would suppress the would
suppress that particular interaction
that would actually prevent us from
seeing see so if we actually look at the
state of a the stated be and what is the
product state of C we can see that in
fact that particular interaction is
consistent and active so interaction a
is active and consistent again
integrating the information from the
states of gene a
B&G and see let's try it again on
interaction too so in interaction too we
now lay on the state for be a was still
there and now we look and see what the
state of D is ok so now when we look at
interaction too we can see that both a
and B should be present in order to have
D in fact what we see is that's not
correct so what we can say from this
analysis is that that interaction should
not be active and is inconsistent lastly
we can look at interaction 3 and in
interaction 3 we have the complex a and
B are both present we have D is present
and we have F is absent and for
interaction a to be active it needs both
the presence of e and the absence of v
and what we can see then is given that f
is absent that we can say that in fact
interaction 3 is in fact is inactive but
consistent okay so we can work that
through all of these 23,000 genes
through all the existing network models
we have and then calculate pathway
signatures as opposed to gene signatures
and what we can see is we get very
different results by using gene they
signatures then using pathway signatures
so in some ways we can reduce
dimensionality or complexity one of the
vexing problems of analyzing genome-wide
fulls of data is the new is the new
merisi of the dimensionality and by
looking at pathways we collapse that
information and actually could do it all
the way down to looking at the overall
state of the collection of interactions
in that particular pathway so we could
either score this pathways having three
units or even all the way down to one we
can also see that it reduce it can
reduce differences so we can see that if
we looked at the gene signatures for
this pathway as opposed to the pathway
consistency that there for differences
so it looks like there's a lot of
difference between individuals but if we
look at the pathway level we can see
that in fact all of the individuals have
a consistent pattern for their pathways
so there's no reason to think
this pathway maybe then have a
differential activity in whatever
phenotype cancer in particular that
we're looking at lastly we can see that
it can amplify differences so by looking
at looking at the network interactions
in the gene states themselves we can see
that in the first example of using gene
signatures there's only really one
difference between the two sets of
signatures but if we look at pathway
consistency scoring at the intersections
we can see that in fact this amplifies
the differences because of changing a
single gene can have a radical effect on
the form of the network okay so what I
want to do is actually move from the
somatic piece to a further work that
we've been interested in is how do we
actually look at constitutional
variation and this is work done by again
a postdoc in my lab rosemary Braun who
actually allowed us to take the emerging
very large collections of G loss data
that exists and say how do the patterns
of that change if we use pathways as I
level analysis rather than jeans as
those of you all familiar with looking
at G wash class studies there's been a
vexing complexity and that we find very
low odds ratios vary load effects
associated with individual genes when we
look at path when we look at jiwa
studies and oftentimes difficulty even
in large-scale studies of reproducing
the findings from studying to study to
study and even when they are
reproducible the effects are very small
our viewpoint I think I'll attempt to
demonstrate by the reanalysis of a
historic data set that rosemary included
in the paper that I showed here that in
fact by looking through the lens of
networks we can get interesting
additional results that are I think are
both interesting and provocative so we
looked for this particular example we
used and wood covered in Rosemary's
papers a the sea gems breast cancer
study population the cancer genomic
markers is susceptibility originally
public it's 2007 very large case control
study that
a genome-wide collection of snips
characterized on the Illumina pathways
and we then looked at the molecular
state of those pathways by looking at
the variation and looking for
differences in the pattern of variation
in these particular genes that are part
of these pathways different from gene
set enrichment or other types of
analysis in the sense that individual
snips don't have to be specifically
significant in order to influence the
molecular State of the pathway and in
fact this type of analysis aggregates in
captures the emergent properties by
doing distance calculations looking at
all of the individual snips in a pathway
simultaneously so that one doesn't have
to first have universal significance of
a given snip and can see the
combinatorial effects of multiple snips
being considered at once so shown here
is actually a pathway of interest of
that that will be particularly clear our
group has the the key finding
historically in the cgm study was the
greatest locus of significance was fgfr2
by itself had an odds ratio of 1.3 very
highly significant odds ratio shown in
this diagram here in the red circle is
where that fgf2 sits in a much more
complicated network that we chose to
analyze and what you can see not
surprisingly even though that we're
looking at breast cancer we can see that
pathway names actually are just like
gene names not always particularly
descriptive of what that pathway is
doing but you can see that fgfr2 with a
different gene nomenclature here is it a
key intersection point in driving
multiple networks associated without
[ __ ] ptosis cell cycle p53 sick
signaling and an other key response to
androgens and other sexual moans as well
so it's at a very interesting
juxtaposition so if we actually now look
at this pathway
instead of just fgf are alone we could
see analyzing this the original result
that was published in the original paper
by a hunter at all they've got an odds
ratio 1.3 if we actually look at this
pathway we can see that this pathway
itself has an odds ratio when we look at
all the genes in it of a slightly higher
value than the original odds ratio that
country awnser 1.38 as opposed to 1.3
but again wildly significant now because
of the multiple combinations and the
reduction in complexity but what becomes
very interesting is that actually if we
drop fgfr2 out of this we see that the
residual members of this network also
contribute to the significance so while
fgfr2 has a very high contribution to
the overall significance of this pathway
we can see that other members of this
pathway equally contribute to
differences between cases can control so
showing that that one of the reasons we
may have difficulty in finding both
higher odds ratios as well as
understanding the complex heterogeneity
of something like breast cancer is it's
not dude simply to fgfr2 but multiple
alterations in a variety of members of
this gene network so shown here I
apologize is a little bit hard to read
but you can see fgf2 the prostate cancer
network actually isn't even the most
significant Network if we look at a
network based analysis of that data set
in fact we can see that there are other
well more significant pathways that are
showing differences between breast
cancer cases and controls not
surprisingly things in purine metabolism
but interestingly to folks who are
familiar with the epidemiology
literature is we see calcium signaling
as an important of pathway modulating
risk for breast cancer and there's been
a large literature that's grown up
around the observation that calcium
intake may be
determining risk for breast cancer in
fact this may be one of those variants
or network collections that I showed
earlier on the slide of cancer that
where we have a network mediating the
interface with environmental exposures
driving individual risk so we can
actually do look to see what would
happen if we started to combine pathways
to the overall odds ratios of
predictions of risk so as I said before
we saw that a single gene fgfr2 has an
odds ratio of 1.3 if we actually combine
the top two pathways we see our odds
ratio now goes up to 2 point 0 and if we
actually combine multiple pathways all
the way down to the bottom we actually
move now from less than a you know a
thirty percent increase in risk to now
over three hundred percent increase in
risk by capturing the variation in a
number of pathways so we change the
character of the problem and actually
moved it into a place by looking at
these networks of having profound
significance between the cases and
controls not just modest significance
and actually having things that a much
more predictive and or diagnostic of
what can occur in it I'll point to that
3.38 as that what you can get from this
this particular single data set with
whopping high significance a you know 10
to the 10 to the minus 95 in terms of
its significance compare this to the
recent publication that came out of that
which sees a lot of coverage of
combinatorial studies and I'll point you
to the breast cancer line that you can
see even even with these combinations of
multiple studies the highest odds ratio
that one gets in considering the highest
five percent so this is already
truncating is two-point-four percent
compared to three-point-three percent
that we got before looking at this
broader population so one might argue
that the use of these networks provides
a very fundamentally different view of
what the problem will look
can they help us better understand
what's occurring in terms of broader
genetic susceptibility so I want to
transition here for a second because one
of the things that I think it's
important for us to realize is that if
we're going to embrace this large shale
collection of problems embrace the
network is nests of cancer as a disease
and all of this multi-dimensional data
what we were actually realize is that
personalized medicine is a big data
problem ok so we've heard a lot about
Big Data you can't actually open a
newspaper nowadays without hearing
people talk about analytics and data and
how big data is going to revolutionize
almost everything in particular
biomedicine I'm going to spend the next
portion of my presentation here talking
through how we how through the embracing
of big data and treating personalized
medicine as a big data problem we may be
able to help not only get coherence
through understanding the complex
adaptive systems nature of cancer but we
may will be able to ask and answer very
complicated questions that are still
largely vexing us when we look at data
not in a big data context so let's start
with what is big data it's a probably
one of the most heavily overused words
right now so big data is minimally not
surprisingly big data so one of the key
dimensions of big data is size but
volume isn't the only thing that
characterizes big data big data is also
characterized by variety variety meaning
many many different sources much
heterogeneity associated with cancer and
then over and above that is velocity
where we need to actually process the
data very very quickly and then be able
to move that data and utilize that data
not in days weeks to months but
hopefully as close to real time as is
possible so
unequivocally when we actually look in
the personalized medicine space a whole
genome analysis all the work that I just
mentioned is a critical dimension of
defining cancer and personalized
medicine as a big data problem shown on
this slide you can see these are numbers
for a single sample the raw data that
comes off of next-generation sequencing
generates 22 you know 220 gigabytes per
sample even as we start to process and
reduce the data we're still into
hundreds of gigabytes in an assembly and
even the variant identification with
resources are measured in hundreds of
megabytes per sample it's also big data
when we talk about the velocity
dimension to get real time or near real
time processing of raw data to
assemblies and assemblies to variance
you can see it takes significant
computer resources dozens of computers
when I say twenty four cores that's
literally 24 separate processors and
computers working 72 hours to work on a
particular problem so you can see
getting to velocity is a very big
challenge in the big data space but
let's be frightening genome data is
about one dimension of the big data
necessary to create personalized a
precision-made medicine it is in some
sense dwarfed by when we bring in data
from the feed home so as a classical
biologist and geneticist that feed oma
is all of the clinical description of an
individual its phenotype but over and
above the phenotype of an individual
what Worf's even the phenotype
characterization is expose oh all a
lifetime's worth of characterization of
all of the external factors that touch
and conceivably modify an organism all
of these are tremendously large sets of
data so let me start with the phenome
data the phenome data is huge it's got
diverse types it's got clinical
observations
Notorious imaging registries
biospecimens and reference knowledge
based sources more lexing and again back
to the both velocity and variety it's
distributed in research settings care
delivery settings and even the care to
Liberty said is in uniform it's got
hospitals individual practical clinical
practices laboratories its present in
registries its present in industries and
actually consumers contain and could
hold key pieces of this information
focusing on just one type of this phenom
data that in and of itself Worf's the
genomic data is imaging data shown here
is a cartoon of whole body imaging
associated with drug delivery that's
going to be increasingly common as we
have non-invasive ways to measure our
interventions each of these individual
images is as large or larger than the
genome spaces that I just mentioned a
moment ago however these are but the tip
of the iceberg when we talk about both
the phenome and expose own the true
explosion of the data the next big data
challenge is going to be in real time
consumer data this is data that may be
monitoring our internal clocks such as
our cardiovascular disease or diabetes
or external or other related monitors
monitoring our food intakes our fitness
or other things and just as of this year
it's expected that they're going to be
about 2 million of these devices
generating continuous streams of data so
this is pretty overwhelming how are we
going to deal with this well again
similar to what I said before what's
exciting about this kind of stuff is the
future is already here and perhaps
borrowing our line from the arm
paraphrasing a line from the movie the
graduate I have one word for you
how are we going to deal with this big
data challenge Google or at least Google
like approaches groups like Google
actually have mastered a whole new
technologic and/or data infrastructure
that blurs computational capacity with
data large data resource and novel
algorithms that allow us to find
patterns in data in near real time so
when we talk about large volumes with
variety it's hard to think of more
variety of data than the internet and
velocity Google processes results in
real time so what do I mean by that it's
actually doing analysis real time well
almost everyone is familiar that as you
sow start to type into a Google search
window it starts to guess what you want
it's doing that by leveraging real-time
analytics that it is performed by
analyzing both millions to billions of
web users like yourself as to what how
what types of words do they put in and
creating complex interaction maps not
unlike the maps I showed for the
molecular diagrams of what actually are
common patterns of use that an
individual might you might be interested
in as they as they are trying to do
their queries anticipating what might
happen by using these complex
interconnected collections of networks
another key example of this would be
amazon who probably in many ways is the
master of this in consumer space where i
think every one of us is familiar where
we go to amazon perhaps enter a
particular search query for a book that
we're interested in in here is a query i
did about looking for a book about big
data in the emerging space of how we
will do interpretation and analysis in
big data space but as everyone is
familiar with as soon as I do my query
amazon immediately figures out that
there might be other books that i might
be interested in and it does this again
by using the underlying correlational
network
structure and big data processing
through things similar to the Hadoop
file systems MapReduce places MapReduce
analytics and a variety of other
sophisticated statistical techniques
that combine and create complex network
maps underneath all of these different
pieces so we're very interested in it in
pushing this this envelope in the fourth
paradigm science data science driven
work work in this instance we actually
use as our experimental platforms not
actually bench based chemistry's or PC
ours or molecular analysis but actually
use this explosion of data in fourth
paradigm science to complement how we do
both discovery and validation using data
as our primary region reagent not
necessarily some wet reagent we think
that its complement data generating
science quite commonly when people talk
about the current type of data they talk
about hypothesis testing I actually
think that that's unfair to data science
to say that we don't do hypothesis
testing folks have been doing data
science with literally hundreds of years
astronomy physics economics I don't
actually go out and move the planets so
I think data science can be just as
important in in testing hypotheses as
traditional bench based experiments but
the key difference here is we're using
data-driven science as opposed to
generating data and then analyzing it up
so the fourth paradigm science is really
data intensive science it moves from the
first paradigm which was just empirical
descriptive science theoretical models
and second paradigm computational
science and third and now data intensive
science would data generated by
large-scale instruments or simulation is
processed by software the information
and/or knowledge is stored in computers
and then the scientist analyzes this
data using data
schmid statistical mathematical or
algorithmic approaches there's not one
tool set that a data scientist uses and
I think someone exciting about this is a
thought one who would have thought ever
thought I guess in the spirit of the
Revenge of the Nerds at least according
to harvard business review data
scientist is the sexiest job of the 21st
century well our equipment ASU has been
very interested in now bringing these
data science approaches to large-scale
genetics and genomics and in this work
we're creating a new data science
instrument what we call the next
generation cyber capability or the NGC
see what we're doing is following in the
tradition of data gathering science that
we're building a scientific instrument
for the data science universe not unlike
the large-scale data gathering
instruments that we're familiar with in
biology you know a genome sequencer but
you know in physics that had run large
collider in astronomy the either space
telescopes or or or the Mars Lander so
what we're interested in doing is
building an instrument that facilitates
the work of data science in data science
we see this instrument as being an
integral or elemental whole of three
dimensions one is physical capacity
ultra high bandwidth networks large
scale storage measured in in hundreds of
petabytes to hundreds excuse me hundreds
of terabytes to hundreds of petabytes
and multiple flavors of computation that
include high performance computing new
big data physical infrastructures that
configure the instrumentation in unique
ways as well as which transactional and
large data reservoirs that facilitate
the capture and manipulate
excuse me these physical capacities are
complemented by logical capabilities
software the management of unique
software necessary to leverage these
physical capacities and to analyze the
data metadata resources that capture or
describe the data that's part of this
large-scale data resources and semantics
understanding of the relationship
between an among data and data elements
lastly in this data set of data science
instrument is not an instrument unless
you bring in the human resources that
transdisciplinary teams that include
folks that know how to run the physical
infrastructure engineers that know how
to create and manage the logical
capabilities as well as then analysts
that know how to leverage the platform
derive what the physical capacity needs
to be and inform the engineers who are
building out those individual capacities
so at ASU are n GCC data science
instrument shown here is a cartoon of
this where we have the logical
capabilities that manage context to
perform analysis that manage the data
and perform transactions supported with
different flavors of high-performance
computing and big data computing managed
through transactional resources that
have a huge data reservoir that allow us
to have large capacity data of what we
can see then on the very right side
heterogeneous content composed of many
many different types of data so we
believe the key of this is connected us
that having the data accessible and
having the metadata and semantic
infrastructure allows us to ask and
answer questions that one simply
couldn't do in a different setting so
why would close the talk with is a
couple examples of how we are leveraging
this type of infrastructure today again
the future already being
you're not a solved problem by any means
but at least the first early Inklings
that by bringing together this
multi-dimensional data we can discover
things that we couldn't do before and in
fact drive and support evidence
generation and understanding of very
complex biomedical problems so a couple
examples of where we're using the N GCC
as an evidence engine using raw data
resources as clinical reference
standards is the starting point here so
in this instance having these complete
collection of resources we use an
infrastructure that we created always at
the National Cancer Institute calling
the calling CA integrator see integrator
brings together diverse information on
radiology molecular characterization as
well as deep information on clinical
resources and what I'm going to show is
just one example by having those
resources at hand and characterized and
defined in a metadata driven
semantically rich way we can ask and
answer questions in real time so one way
we can ask an answer question is
starting with a particular disease case
in this instance it would be somebody
with GBM where a individual radiologist
has characterized the characteristics of
this particular individuals disease and
then by using those characteristics we
can query this big data integrated
resource and find or make predictions is
to whether someone with this
individual's characteristics has
differential survival from an individual
who duck for the vast majority
population that doesn't have these
characteristics so if you look on this
slide you can see the kaplan-meier plot
calculated for other people in our deep
data resource what's their survival look
like for the in this instance five
individuals that have the same
characteristics as this individual and
how does that contrast to the survival
of individuals who have different
characteristics does this make your
survival better or worse for
Multi forum that other than other types
of characterization we've also actually
done this big data technology
proof-of-concept in partnership with our
colleagues at Booz Allen Hamilton with
which collections of molecular data data
from the Cancer Genome Atlas data from
the NCI nature pathway interaction
database from the NCI cancer gene index
and the Suffolk gene / drug database
that allows us to ask multiple
complicated queries and in this instance
we can ask and answer queries of the
type shown here so for instance there
sample clinical research queries that we
can say for tumor samples which are from
patients who had progressive disease we
can bring up all of the genes which are
in a high amplification chromosomal
region and their gene name so we can
actually see what are the genes that
might be driving progressive disease
based on their amplification status
similarly we can actually retrieve the
gene expression scores of all the genes
that your high amplification region with
a known high expression pro along with
the information about the sex
chemotherapy treatment and the lifespan
so in other words by looking at the
genes sort of the converse of the
previous experiment we can retrieve the
genes that appear to be influencing once
chemotherapy that are modified by
chemotherapy treatments and have an
effect on the overall outcome lastly in
this particular set of candidate queries
that we can support through this we can
retrieve the set of genes which have a
documented association with one or more
drugs and that are expressed at or over
a specified threshold but are not known
in a high amplification region so we can
actually look for genes that aren't
being driven by molecular alterations
associated with amplifications but
instead by alterations that are that are
as yet uncharacterized so we could go
back and try to figure out what's
driving those particular types of
modifications of course our big goal is
not to be able
these clinical research questions but to
really support the transition into the
clinic itself that would allow us to say
given the clinical demographic and
lifestyle characteristics of the
patients how to survival differ on
alternative interventions one of the one
of the adverse events associated with
alternative interventions and what are
the quality of life difference is
associated with alternative
interventions and you know then based on
given all the above can we make a
recommendation from using these as
supporting tools can we make a
recommendation to a physician and or to
a patient what might be the alternative
courses or least inform the patient
and/or care provider what would be the
consequences of alternative intervention
in an evidence-based fashion leveraging
all of this heterogeneous and complex
data that would be in the system so i'm
going to close with a quick summary we
think that unique insights can come from
addressing cancer is a complex adaptive
system and they may help address some of
the challenges that we currently face in
particular in cancer it we think it's
technically feasible to create deploy
these we've shown a couple of examples
both in our own house as well as in the
community where this is already
happening we think we get unique
coherence by using network models to
augment the genome the sort of lineal
organization or gene-specific
characterization of particular work and
we believe that you know in order to
solve these problems we're going to need
to not only have multi-dimensional data
but actually multi-dimensional
communities to help address these so I
welcome you all we would love to have
you be part of our community anyone who
would be interested in playing with us
and would be interested in collaborating
on please feel free to contact me at
Kenneth buetow at asu.edu and with that
what I wanted to do is a point you all
to where you need to go I'll remind you
this
after I open up the session for
questions but to point you to this URL
ww bio conference live.com in order to
go get the CM e or Cee credits
associated with this particular module
that's where you would go to actually
perform that the next steps to get the
CME credit so with that with a few
minutes left I'm going to open the floor
for questions I'm going to see if we
actually have any questions that have
been put forward again feel free to type
these into your particular viewing
screen as a right now I don't have any
formal questions but we'll wait a minute
or two and see if folks have any
specific questions again while we're
waiting I'll remind you to for capture
of the continuing education or
continuing medical education it can go
to www bio conference live com all right
well at this point I don't see any
questions I'm happy to entertain them if
there are others that are interested but
in the absence thereof will wait for
just a minute so feel free if you have
questions to enter them into the queue a
box so i guess i'll take at this point
seeing no specific questions i want to
thank you all for your attention and
participatory for me what are some of
the Expos own characteristics that you
have derived so in this instance we're
actually not deriving expose own
characteristics we're actually capturing
them so in this instance they would be
quite commonly exposures so for instance
in work that I'm working on that I
didn't present in today's presentation
some of the exposure work I'm studying
is that liver cancer it would include
the state of whether you are infected by
one or more of that hepatitis viruses
hepatitis B hepatitis B hepatitis C it
could also include the weather your your
obesity status so we're actually very
interested in looking at how one's
obesity status drives development of
liver disease and/or liver cancer other
questions so it says do you work on the
next question is do you work on o de or
or PDE simulations so for the most part
right now we haven't been doing
simulations tied to the particular work
although the infrastructure that we have
actually would support any of these
different types of flavors of
simulations other questions
ah the next question is in 1971
president richard nixon announced a war
on cancer how long do we need to wait
wait for a week let's see how long do we
need to wait for real treatments I
actually think that's an appropriate
fair question I think part of the
challenge that we faced in the cancer
community and part of I think the new
opportunity before us is it we spent a
lot of time taking cancer apart
understanding its individual components
through reductionist paradigms I think
the opportunity that's before us right
now is to synthesize or integrate those
pieces so I'm cautiously optimistic that
as we start the kind of work that I just
described in this talk of not looking or
hoping that there's going to be a single
Magic Bullet drug for a single gene but
recognize that as we saw for GBM there's
multiple networks that have multiple
alterations that if we start to assemble
those pieces in comprehensive strategies
then we're going to have much more
effective treatments now I'd like to
think that that's going to happen very
very quickly but that said I think that
that transition is occurring as we speak
and you'll look as we see right now from
calls from the NIH for instance for its
big data to knowledge transformations we
can see that in fact there is real work
going on right now to try to change the
characteristics of those so I would like
to say that the breakthrough changes are
just around the corner but I actually
wanted not generate the ongoing pipe
that we've had in the cancer community
for a long time and I think we still
have a bit of a slog ahead of us but but
in a recent conference that I
participated in there is significant
hope that within the next decade many of
the major cancers that we face today
that
life-threatening will be transformed
into will be transformed into not
life-threatening but chronic manageable
diseases the next question asks if am I
looking at a vitamin D status in the
specific work that I'm working on right
now I'm not working particularly on
vitamin D status but I know for a
variety of different cancers vitamin D
status is a significant interest and in
theory in the exposé on space would be
one of the critical things I think we
would want to be able to bring in to the
types of analysis we perform another
question says do you foresee a push back
in big data usage in life sciences after
the NSA surveillance leakage the short
answer is I hope not partially because
unlike the NSA we in biomedicine have
been very very upfront with use and
reuse of data we unlike them you know
NSA consent and or engage the patients
about what the data is and upfront tell
them what will be the circumstances and
they have the right to determine when
their data will be used and won't be
used that said I think we are going to
see changes in how liberal or
comfortable people are so i think that
there's likely to be you know some
pushback ok the next question says that
my big data concerns fall well within
the realm of estimation theory and
decision sugar you mentioned effectively
through let's see I think this is what
drugs so i'm not sure i can actually
formally answer which eggs have changed
let's see from this i don't think i have
the whole question so is it the next
question i see is what drugs have
changed pancreatic cancer prognosis and
any specific gene markers
I'm not certainly an expert in that
space so I unfortunately we'll have to
defer that to someone else so my
apologies for not being able to help
with that any other questions that we
have so our next question is how complex
can be the complexity of cancer if
epigenetic complexes enhance the
complexity of cancer treatment I think
it actually can be quite complex the
epigenetic changes actually have
profound ways to change large-scale
components now that said it's through
the embracing of complexity that we can
actually see those changes and if we
actually look on a gene by Gene basis
that the signals look chaotic but if we
embrace the complexity what we see in
fact is is again a coherence of regions
that are being turned on and or turned
off by epigenetic changes and that these
epigenetic cancer treatments actually
then may actually facilitate the
transformation or deactivation of cancer
and oncogenic phenotypes another
question is how will Big Data impact the
role of subject matter expertise in the
modern world I think it's actually
within the spirit of I open this talk
with both revolution and Renaissance I
actually think it's going to be
revolutionary I think by releasing the
data and harvesting this diverse
resources that historically have been
locked away in unaccessible subject
matter expertise will be greatly
expanded so in other words one won't
have to master every domain in order to
utilize all of the domains of data and
knowledge so much the same as the web
allows me to ask and answer questions in
real time of to which these information
I would have never known about it
changes that the data will facilitate
that as well and then I think for last
question is
it necessary to work with computational
studies that should have mathematical
expertise I think the cool part of the
new big data problem is that in fact it
doesn't require just a simple single
approach to the problem okay I think
we're out of time at this point I want
to thank you all for your participation
I think it's been having the opportunity
to interact with you thank you for your
questions and at this point I thank you
for your participation and and say
goodbye so thank you